collier tours de roues
alors ça donne quoi ce test ça va ils
sont une vingtaine sur 200 salariés à
bénéficier de ce dispositif
le prêt gratuit d'un vélo électrique
entièrement équipée pendant un mois des
candidats volontaires aux motivations
variées déjà économique financièrement
et économie aussi pour les pour la
planète souplesse aussi vu les villes
qui sont de plus en plus congestionnées
par les voitures le fait que l'on
développe de plus en plus de pistes
cyclables donc entrer dans cette danse
née dans ce mouvement qui a été et qui a
été déclenchée déployé depuis le mois de
juin le dispositif good watts s'adresse
aux entreprises des grandes
agglomérations pour un coût réduit 3500
euros au lieu de 18 me de plus en plus
de nos salariés nous challenge et sur la
mobilité donc on a eu une offre qui a
été fait par l'entreprise godoy qui
porte un projet européen
et financé par l'ademe et le timing
s'est trouvé être le goût
d'aller vous allez sentir l'assistance
qui va vous assistez pas rendez vous
allez dépasser 25 km/heure
l'assistance elles se coupent accord
chaque vidéo est également équipé d'une
puce qui recueille les données
d'utilisation pour notamment calculé
l'économie carbone le nombre de
kilomètres parcourus par jour le nombre
de trajets domicile travail etc toutes
ces infos derrière on va les regrouper
on va les condensés et on va leur
proposer un bilan à la fin du mois et
est assise cas l'employeur on leur
propose un bilan global qui regroupe
toutes les données d'utilisation de tous
les vélos de manière anonyme des données
qui permettent aussi d'évaluer
l'engouement des salariés est d'inciter
les entreprises à créer des aides à
l'achat jusqu'à présent 70 % des
utilisateurs se disent prêts à adopter
cette nouvelle pratique